[Music]
hello everybody
it's monday here we are
once again talking about another movie
yep i'm trying to get this [ __ ] started
[Laughter]
another week although at this point you
know it doesn't really matter
because we're just kind of working every
day and so it doesn't really matter what
day it is
so the one we're talking about today
this is a shutter original
they just added it a few days ago and
this is called
anything for jackson this came out this
year
now one of the funniest things about
this that i didn't know while i was
watching it but the director
uh justin g dyke i'm not sure if this is
his first horror movie
but what he did before doing this movie
was he directs those cheesy like tv
christmas movies that they make like 40
bajillion of like every holiday season
like on hallmark channel yeah like stuff
like that like a very country christmas
and like christmas in paris and stuff
like that so he was like no
he had done like a [ __ ] ton of those but
i have to say
that if this is his first horror movie
dude you need to make more horror movies
because this was like i found this movie
really
entertaining it's pretty good it's not
um
it's interesting because okay so the
setup of it is
you have this elderly couple uh henry
and audrey
and they have lost their grandson
jackson and their daughter too like in a
terrible
car accident and they apparently
can't deal with the grief so like you do
they decide that they're going to join a
satanic cult
kidnap a pregnant woman and essentially
channel jackson's spirit into
the pregnant woman's baby they're
talking about like a reverse
exorcism yeah that's kind of that's kind
of how they're like pitching this movie
yeah
and like when you say that that's what
the premise is it almost sounds like
it's gonna be the zany like over-the-top
comedy but it's really not
it's not it doesn't take itself entirely
seriously
but it's not like a comedy either you
know what i'm saying i think it like
it strikes a good balance between having
like some actual
really creepy [ __ ] going on in it
because like some of the ghosts
because what ends up happening is that
you know the two of them
are clearly like kind of out of their
league
uh you know what i mean because they
just kind of are dabbling in it i
suppose
and um what ends up happening is that
while they're doing the rituals and [ __ ]
they don't really do them right so they
get like all these other
demons like essentially they're opening
up like a portal and like all these
other kind of demons and ghosts and [ __ ]
like wander through
so all this like crazy [ __ ] starts
happening around their house but like
some of the
other like spirits and stuff that they
put in this like the woman with the
flake floss in her teeth
and uh the dude like the contortionist
dude like with the bag on his head that
was like they were like really really
creepy
and they really did a good job like
oscar right there just the contortionist
dude
because it looks that did not look like
cgi i think it's i don't think
i don't think that was cgi he was a real
guy he's walking on all fours but
backwards with his head
it looked it looked good i thought it
looked really good too creepy
like like i said it really did not
plastic bag over it like it was
suffocating
yeah and it's like and i almost kind of
like that they don't really explain like
it's like it's like i said it's
they opened a portal and like all this
[ __ ] like starts wandering because
they've been running up their people and
[ __ ]
yeah so it's i think this came out
really good because
it's almost kind of like like
because it's an old couple at the you
know cut who are like the villains
but they're also like really sympathetic
because they
well kind of kind of sympathetic i mean
well because
you can understand like yeah what
they're doing is like crazy as [ __ ]
but you can understand why because
they're clearly like you know grieving a
lot like losing their grandson
um you know not saying what they did was
cool or anything but they they seem like
a lot nice it's almost kind of like the
cast of vets from rosemary's baby
but not as like um
not as straight up evil as that and not
like as obnoxious
because they seem like just very kindly
old people
they don't seem like sinister in any way
yeah what they're doing is pretty
[ __ ] bad though
it is yeah well obviously
i know you liked the movie i liked it
okay too but there's just something
about
some of these newer movies where it's
just all kinds of generic movie-like
stuff
they start to kind of blur together you
know there's a lot of movies that are
like this
yeah it does have a different spin to it
but yeah
all in all for me this one it really
didn't rise to the [ __ ] level of
where
it'd be real memorable that's just just
me maybe it had to do with mindset of
watching it at the time
um it wasn't a bad movie yeah it was
just
kind of mediocre in a certain ways but
you know what that's i'm not saying i'm
not
singling this movie out they're all kind
of or most of them are kind of like that
to me now
just gonna say you know from from this
era and maybe it's maybe they were
always kind of like that most movies
were mediocre but
i don't know there's just something
about it that that didn't really catch
me that much
i don't know i really like like i said i
wasn't my favorite one that i've seen
recently but i really liked
um the different take on it like because
there's like a lot of exorcism movies
but i liked kind of the different take
on it i like that it had like a little
bit
of a dark comedy kind of edge but not
like in a real overt way
i think it has something to do with the
way that they look they all kind of look
alike to me
like mandy looked very different met
movie mandy well that one stuck out
you know that one was immediate well
yeah because that was like a visual
right
and and to me a lot of these horror
movies visually they just look a lot
they just
they're like the same movie well just
like everything else there's trends
in filmmaking so i mean you can usually
like if you see like a horror movie from
the 90s you can usually tell
yeah like all the filters or lighting or
whatever they use because things go in
and out of fashion
so maybe it's just that you know
you know it's just kind of like a trend
of like let's make you know the movie
look
architecture the color palettes just you
know i mean the lighting the shot
composition this
are all just kind of looking alike to me
yeah i guess i guess i could see that i
think that might have come about
because maybe because of the success of
the conjuring universe
because i feel like yeah once the
conjuring came out and it was like this
massive success and spawned this big
franchise and everything i think a lot
of other
lower budget like supernatural type
movies like tried to kind of
mimic that look maybe maybe what it is i
think maybe this i'm not sure
because it might have been becoming
prevalent before that i
wasn't really thinking about it too much
while i was watching the movie it's now
that i'm done
seeing it looking back on it there you
know what i mean after a few days
they start to kind of blend in together
to become the same
yeah i start to get them kind of
confused and i think it's because
visually they all look alike
because they're similar looking they're
similar looking yeah i know what you're
saying i get what you're saying
yeah it does seem like a lot of like
ghost story like and like i said when
you know maybe we talked about this i
don't remember if we talked about this a
little bit when i was talking about that
spanish one that we watched the other
day
but you know even though i really do
like these movies it does take a lot for
i mean i see like a lot more a lot of
horror movies
so even though i like a lot of them when
i see them
like sometimes like a year later i can't
remember yeah like remember remember
that
hansel and gretel yeah or gretel and
hansel
yeah yeah that we saw in the theater
yeah that movie was just a
piece of [ __ ] just i just all right but
visually i thought it was great i can
remember it
yeah you know what i mean well it looked
different it looks very different just
the way the witch's house looked the
[ __ ] that the witch
did and i can remember it you know i
mean it did have its own identity
um and i kind of had a positive feeling
about the way that it looked about that
way and
i wanted more scenes with just the witch
i didn't give a [ __ ] about
the kids or the woodsmen or the mom or
the family yeah you know what i mean
but the witch and the witch's house i
liked
and um just some of the [ __ ] that that
witch did down in the basement and stuff
so the way a movie looks has a lot to do
with it for me
yeah it's very visual you know yeah that
was it i thought gretel and hanzo was a
piece of [ __ ] movie but the witch in it
was [ __ ]
great and the way it looked that was the
same chick that was in ghost story like
way back in the day
alice creed whatever yeah yeah harvey
and perhaps it was one of those star
wars or something
but the writing of that movie think of
that thing that greg gretel
the writing of that movie was very
disjointed and it had a [ __ ]
terrible flow to it and it it just
wasn't interesting but i really did like
her as a witch and honestly i don't i
wonder if anybody's done this because i
know they've done like a lot of hansel
and gretel
adaptations um and other kind fairy tale
adaptations i'd be interested to know if
anybody pulled
like a wicked um you know where they
made like a whole thing about the wicked
witch of the west
but if they did that with the witch from
hansel and gretel
like with the candy house and all that
kind of [ __ ] because i would totally
watch that
but i feel like i don't know it's
i guess it depends on what kind of movie
that you're making
sometimes i like um
you know the this just the dark like
colorless kind of look because sometimes
that works
but honestly sometimes i i think you're
right i think
maybe we it would be better if like some
movies were more
colorful or had more like a distinctive
right
look to them yeah this one was it looked
very generic
and for me film of course is a visual
medium
you know i mean it has to have a it
can't look realistic that's the thing
i think it started with the haunting
universe it looked like something you
shot out of your cell phone in a certain
way
not really a little bit more corporate
than that but it's
it's it's not a very vibrant feel to
anything muted colors and stuff
and like i said i do feel like that's a
trend yeah just because
you know it's it seems like that people
think that makes it scarier
like i guess if it's like dark and kind
of grayish blue or something that would
mean
it's just kind of like you remember this
maybe was 90s or 2000s where everything
was either
like blue filter or orange filter right
yeah
or one or it went back and forth between
the two things i feel like that was
maybe like an early 2000s thing
where like all the movies had that like
color tinge to them
somehow you got to get emotion across
yeah
with with film that's why i [ __ ]
talked about mandy
mandy the story isn't complicated
but man there's a whole hell of a lot of
emotion and it kind of brings it across
visually everything is like a
frankfurzeta acid trip
yeah yeah like everything looks like a
painting yeah and everything's all
distorted and stuff and just the way the
people act it's kind of distorted and
you're like
man that that was like a masterpiece i
thought
well it's kind of going back to like the
expressionist films where they're trying
to show like people's emotions and
psychosis like through the
through the exterior like like you're
there like right
here like you're having the experience
it's almost like first person and you're
getting the emotions too
that's what i would say that's all i'm
going to say about this movie in terms
of it's it's not a bad movie
but it's definitely a movie of its time
you know yeah
it's kind of and i'm kind of getting
sick of this
you know what i mean i like i like a
little more variation in things
yeah i did really like this one and like
i said it's
i like that it wasn't that long it
didn't like fart around with a lot of
stuff like the girl gets kidnapped like
in the first like
two or three minutes of the movie um and
they kind of set it up i really really
like
um the performances of the two love the
elderly couple
it's weird because like the dude that
plays henry
who is an obstetrician that's how he
knew
about the pregnant woman because she was
his patient um
is played by julian richings and the
whole time i'm looking at him going god
damn it i've seen that dude
in movies before and i couldn't place
him so i had to go to his like imdb page
he's been like in a bunch of [ __ ]
but i think that i'm remembering him
from
a christmas horror story because i just
saw that not too long ago and
uh he was also in the witch and he was
in
um the last will and testament of
rosalind lee
which actually i think that might be
that's like one of the editors from
rumored magazine
that was like his movie and i actually
really really liked that one that might
be on shutter
as well or it might be on netflix i
can't i saw that one better i mean some
cool [ __ ] happens in the movie dude
[ __ ] throws himself into a snow
blower that was pretty cool you know
yeah i like that people shoot themselves
it's
over and over again yeah because you
never know when a demon might possess
you and get you to do something stupid
you know
there there's it does have some good
aspects
you know it's not a bad movie like i
said just it lacks
visual style for me yeah that's all but
i mean
you know other than that i actually
really liked this movie and it was and
it was one that
stood out to me like um just from a
story point of view because they were
kind of doing something a little bit
different
you know what i mean like with the
possession thing like i said it's almost
kind of like they took
the cast of vets from rosemary's baby
and were making [ __ ] from their point of
view but made them like less
psychotic and more not more sympathetic
more understandable like why they were
doing what they were doing
you know what i mean because the cast
events were just satanists they didn't
like
they didn't have like any i don't think
they had any excuses to like why they
were doing the [ __ ] they were going
but uh but yeah so it's on shutter uh if
you want to watch it if you like like
possession movies you like
like evil old people movies any kind of
[ __ ] like that then uh by all means
check it out because
i don't know i really liked it um i can
see what you're saying about the visual
thing
yeah because you talk about the evil old
people and it just kind of kind of
reminded me what it reminded me remember
the one about the all evil old people
and the woman who pretend who
i guess she had alzheimer's maybe she
was pretending that she was all having
all so i remember that one which kind of
reminded me of that movie
i don't know it was a movie like this
that's all i could say
remember that they were in there they
were it was in england and they were
they were robbing the house
oh yeah yeah and then they the old
people came home and they
but it turned out the old people were
more evil than the right and i said that
that
that movie was actually not bad but that
movie reminded me straight up of lucio
folgi's house of classes
well visually and everything that movie
reminded me of this or this movie
reminded me of the reminder
kind of reminds me that was a british
movie i think that was a british movie
there's just something about the color
palettes and the way this stuff is shot
where it's all starting to look alike
yeah i get what you're saying yeah
although i will say and i'm not don't
now don't spoil it
but the movie that we're going to review
tomorrow which is one that's like
actually a couple of years old
uh definitely does not suffer from that
yeah because
i don't even know if you know which one
i'm talking about oh
okay i'll remember it later i'm i'm
excited to talk about it because
the other there are so many of them the
movie that we're going to review
tomorrow is like i'm really
really excited about it so i'm just
surprised that i didn't see it until now
because it's like a few years old
but yeah so we'll talk about that
tomorrow but like i said i'll keep it a
secret
all right so i'm gonna cut it a little
bit short today
i guess although we've been going for 20
minutes so it's not too bad
all right so uh we'll be back tomorrow
with another movie review
and uh thanks for stopping by as always
we'll see you guys again tomorrow
bye